[Music]
you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
this has got to be the weirdest set of
circumstances I've ever had to review a
phone like little-known fact I've I've
dropped and scratched an unreleased
phone before I even got to shoot any
footage of it I've had software updates
dramatically changed the way I felt
about a phone in the middle of shooting
the review so weird stuff has happened
behind the scenes but this is this is a
lot so I want hands on with the phone
for the first time then I dropped my
video on the first impressions of it
then I went home with one and then I
broke it and then I got replaced and
then I found out all the reviewers had
theirs break for similar related reasons
made a whole video about that and now
this device is getting delayed and
Samsung is actually going to change it
before it actually comes out and ships
to people who bought it so this is the
Samsung Galaxy fold kinda it's it's the
part one the pre review there's an
official statement from Samsung saying
they'll be strengthening the display and
it'll be a little bit different when it
actually comes out and gets released but
until then this is more of a review of
the rest of the execution on this whole
foldable phone concept so right off the
bat I love that this is it's just so
different I mean we're so used to the
slab the glass front and back that when
you have a whole new form factor there's
just so much more to talk about to think
about so let's talk about it so one of
the earliest thoughts that's floated
around in my head about the Galaxy fold
is it's more like a folding tablet than
a folding phone so you have this little
baby 4.7 inch display on the outside
with I mean let's be honest comically
big bezels and even that number it makes
the screen seem bigger than it is
with the rounded corners it even says on
the box it's basically a 4.6 inch
display and then even with that it's
much narrower than normal so it feels
like the same width as a three point six
inch display all that to say it's small
so what you want to do is open it up and
use the 7.3 inch four by three OLED
display that's on the inside that's
where the magic happens that's the whole
point of this foldable phone evolution
is fitting a display this big in your
pocket still so the galaxy fold this
version of it is definitely chunky like
this is a thick phone with maybe three
or four C's
it doesn't fold completely flat as you
can see there's a gap in the middle of
mine with a hinge all of them have this
sort of a triangle shape and then yeah
the more you look at it the more it sort
of reminds me of two narrow phones
connected to each other from a lot of
angles like it has the weight of two
phones it fits in your pocket like two
phones it's really a lot of material so
it turns out this is a fragile phone and
you can tell it as soon as you pick it
up like it's pretty fragile and that's
because of really two main pieces the
hinge and the soft plastic on the inside
so of course glass doesn't fold make a
folding phone you need something other
than glass so you have plastic on this
outside and then of course you need a
hinge somewhere and this hinge from
Samsung is this crazy complex mechanism
with gears and this big cover over the
back and it's a scary piece because
there's speculation that dirt and dust
can slide its way into this hinge
through the gears and all the way up
into the phone behind the display which
may have caused a review unit to break
which is pretty crazy but that will
hopefully change with the updated
version so I don't want to spend too
much time on that but what I will say is
even though it's rated for 200,000 folds
by a robot in a lab I mean you can
literally wobble this thing with your
bare hands like there's give to this
hinge I am literally terrified for the
jerryrigeverything test when he finally
gets his because I'd bet money it's just
gonna snap in half like I'd bet real
money on that but you got to have a
hinge so there is one here and then the
other delicate piece is a soft plastic
screen and this is the part that Samsung
had the most difficulty with with all
the review units that is the part that
they're definitely changing on the
updated version of this phone but even
if they do make it stronger it's still
gonna be just one of the weak points of
this first generation folding phone just
because that's where material science
and tech is right now so one of the
biggest questions about the Galaxy fold
unfolded is yeah how bad is that crease
you know how bad is it can you see it
pretty much everyone who's watched a
video of the Galaxy fold has just stared
at that crease so something I've noticed
about that it seems like and you can
look this up it feels like pretty much
everyone complaining about the crease is
people who don't have one that are
watching a video of the crease and just
noticing it and then people who do have
one are mostly saying it's not a huge
deal I fall somewhere in the middle
because obviously like kind of like a
notch if you
stare at it of course it looks horrible
and you're gonna notice that absolutely
and this one has a notch too but this
crease like if you're in a brightly lit
environment or if you have a light
wallpaper that's something you're gonna
see that's why Samsung has a black
wallpaper by default on this phone but
for me when you're looking at the phone
straight on and you're focused on the
content you know whatever game or video
you're in and what you're watching I
don't see the crease at all so then I'm
super immersed and it looks fantastic
but then I'll look at it off access for
like a second or I'll catch my finger
running over it too many times like even
when the phone's flat you can feel it
and then you remember it's there and
it's not so hot so the mild crease is
just one of those things that you're
gonna have to accept in a
first-generation folding phone that's
just part of the tech the Galaxy fold
shares a lot of things with the Galaxy S
10 a lot of the good parts actually
which make it feel a little less
first-gen so it has the same high-end
specs snapdragon a 55 12 gigs of ram and
then materials of course so the glass
and the metal everywhere and the
speakers are actually a bit better than
the s10 so you have the ones at the
bottom and the ones at the top and it
actually creates a sort of a stereo
speaker separation so there you go a
hidden advantage of having a gigantic
device is the speakers are so far apart
and can have so much room that they're
actually better than normal closer to a
tablet speaker that's cool and then of
course you have mainly the same software
as the s10 2 1 UI is still doing a good
job as far as reach ability and
organization responsiveness etc it's
pretty good I have had a couple of
random weird bugs with the fold though
like Spotify lockscreen music controls
haven't worked at all for me which is
kind of weird because I use them all the
time and I had this weird app drawer
overlap bug that only a restart of the
device fixed other than that though it's
been pretty solid and then there are two
main software features added to the fold
multitasking which is a little adjusted
and continuity multitasking for me
wasn't a huge deal mainly because I've
had multitasking on big phones before on
this huge screen on the fold you can
have three apps side-by-side in this
triple window and then you can keep
adding floating windows up to eight apps
open at once and the 12 gigs of ram
handles it fine but again like I'm a
person who will probably just stick to
two at once
and I feel like it's great in this
nearly square format because now it's
feeling like two full size phones next
to each other again but continuity
though that
is a core feature of a folding phone
going from the small to the large and
back to the small again and it's worked
in the Galaxy fold better than I've seen
in any other folding phone demo so I was
impressed by continuity and it was fast
so you have an app open on the small
screen you want to get into it so you
open up the fold it opens up and it
picks up right where you left off so the
apps that are supported best basically
the ones from Google and Samsung right
now will be the best at remembering
everything about your small screen state
and transferring it perfectly and then
with some other apps there will be a
kind of a reset timeline or scrolling
which can be kind of annoying and then
in the very few apps that don't support
it at all going from the small screen to
the big screen will give you a blown-up
version of the phone screen and then
you'll have to hit this button in the
corner to restart the app to get the new
aspect ratio from my experience it was a
surprising amount of apps pretty much
all the apps I use except for a youtube
studio worked in some way with
continuity which was cool so by default
when you close the fold it just goes to
sleep just because that's usually what
you're doing when you close it you're
going to sleep and you're done using it
but there is a setting that will allow
you to continue using apps from the big
screen to the small screen so in the
display settings it's called continued
apps on front screen so you can turn
that on too if you go in there and check
like Google Maps or accurate weather for
example then you have an app open on the
big screen you close the fold and it'll
wake up where you left off on the
smaller screen this will also continue
to get better with Android cue as Google
and Samsung continue to work on it but
it's already pretty impressive to me
it's already miles better than the
barely functional real flex pay I saw at
CES okay so the rest of my thoughts on
the Galaxy fold are I guess pretty
random but let's talk about it so
opening the fold in general is clumsy
with these magnets and these buttons and
how thick the phone is it's constantly a
bit of a battle for me closing it is
easy you just slap it shut and it's fine
but opening it always like you have to
pry it apart and I feel like I just
never got used to that it's always a
two-handed action the bezels on the
front screen yeah they are super ugly
but I'm also pretty sure Samsung knows
this too like this is not what they
would have wanted to make they would
have rather made a bezel as if they
could so that
leads me to believe they were kind of
forced to make it like this maybe the
tech in the hinge in other parts rink
the front screen down pretty bad there's
an I fix that tear down but that's
suddenly gone but that's what I believe
the battery of the fold is fantastic it
is split in half like I've said so
there's a cell in each half of this
phone that add up to four thousand three
hundred eighty milliamp hours and I've
had great battery life on the fold which
is really impressive considering
something with so much screen and then I
got to say this phone might have been
even more awesome with an S Pen right up
the side obviously since it can't fold
of course but I'm guessing there isn't
enough space for that and it's not even
a Galaxy Note fold but I'm just you know
imagining how dope would it be to pop it
open take notes on that huge screen and
then just close it just a thought the
Samsung default keyboard is actually
split when you open the phone I actually
prefer this Google keyboard and I've
been using it and it's not split but I
suspect that people with smaller hands
will appreciate the default split
keyboard design and the Galaxy fold is
super awkward as a GPS in your car so
you don't want to use it with the tiny
four point whatever inch screen but when
folded open it's way too wide for any of
those clamping car mounts or even a cup
holder or anything so yeah someone's
gonna have to make a sort of specialized
car mount for this thing that holds it
unfolded so you can use the nav as a big
screen the Bigsby button underneath the
fingerprint reader is the worst I'm
convinced Samsung was like oh we can
just put the Bigsby button in there
quietly and they won't even notice it
because they'll be so focused on the
fold
yeah no I'm talking about it Samsung
it's not it's not the move it's
straight-up route just the form factor
of the Galaxy fold unfolding it so many
times you're gonna accidentally press
that button constantly and you know we
don't want to use big speed but hey they
dropped it in there so at least you can
turn it from being a single press to a
double press to open Bixby so there are
less accidental triggers of your
favorite voice assistant and then
actually agree with a lot of what dieter
from the verge was saying in his review
about the front screen of course it's
super small and because it's so bad
looking most people won't want to use it
most of the time I'm doing something
quick on it like taking a phone call or
music controls or messing with podcasts
or just something quick that you can use
on the small screen and then put it back
away but you know those times where you
just take out your phone
do one quick thing and then suddenly
it's 15 minutes later and you're just
mindlessly scrolling through Instagram
yeah that doesn't really happen on this
front screen so it doesn't really happen
on this phone the screen is so small you
don't really want to do anything on it
so anytime you want to really get into
something or get some work done you have
this intentional opening the fold action
and then you're using it then you're
getting work done or whatever you were
gonna do when you're done you close it
up and you don't really ever have those
like getting lost moments of wandering
around on that small screen it's
interesting so at the end of the day
like I said in that broken video I was
never really gonna recommend people go
out and buy the two thousand dollar
generation one galaxy fold why you may
ask well for a two in one or a
convertible whatever you want to call
this to actually be worth it in any
category it generally needs to either be
better than or cheaper than having to
get both things in that category so for
all those crazy laptops that fold
backwards and have a touchscreen in
there these two and one convertibles
those are trying to be both a laptop and
a tablet and a lot of those are
specialized at being a better laptop
than most or being a better tablet than
most or they're just straight-up cheaper
than buying both a laptop and a tablet
the galaxy fold is trying to be a phone
and a tablet but it's not a better phone
than most and it's not a better tablet
than most and a two thousand bucks it
sure as hell isn't cheaper than just
buying a Galaxy S ten and a tablet so
yeah I'm not gonna tell you to buy it
but what I will tell you to do is when
these actually do start showing up in
stores go into a store and try it like
pick it up hold it unfold it close it
like get that feeling of actually having
this huge screen that you can fit in
your pocket as a concept folding your
tablet and being able to put it in your
pocket that's that's the main advantage
that's what will make these better than
most tablets and then the fact that it
can be a phone on top of that too is a
nice bonus so I like the concept but
this is of course generation 1 of what I
to now believe after using it that this
will be the future of smartphones or the
future of
or both you know this clamshell design
reminds me of this is this right here is
everything the LG Voyager ever wanted to
be like this this right here with the
all touchscreen and if phones can get as
good as they did in the last 12 years
from the LG Voyager till now then I'm
pretty excited for what smartphones are
gonna turn into from this first gen
folding phone over the next couple of
years so I'm thankful for Samsung
willing to jump in early and get it
started to everyone hating on the Galaxy
fold I get it it's so easy it's really
easy to see a phone like this come along
and it's 2,000 bucks and it's got this
hinge down the middle and I know it's
been tough to like find real big flaws
with phones lately so when you see
something like this oh you got a dive in
this is your time to shine this is this
is the one to hate on but for those of
us that actually get excited about new
technology this is one of the few truly
new form factors and and new first gen
concepts in a long time and for it to
have this much promise this early is
actually pretty exciting it's pretty
cool there's gonna have to be a part two
of this review with final hardware when
that's eventually a thing but until then
I'm gonna send this back to Samsung I'm
gonna let them work on it I'm gonna
cross my fingers until it gets good then
until then thanks for watching
catch you guys later peace